oh yeah
yeah
stop it what a gorgeous Thursday it is
and not just cause Pete exeth is here
yeah he's so hot AOC wants to ban him
along with gas stoves
he's so hot he could be my twin brother
[Laughter]
you know what I'm exaggerating anyway
I'm way hotter we're gonna tackle the
whole Biden classified document scandal
in mere minutes
but first let's do this shall we
the audience
[Applause]
a show that does this probably for a
reason here's a refresher I'm going to
give you two topics and whichever gets
the most Applause wins very simple by
the way it's the same way Pete picks out
a speedo
just opens the drapes
what do you like there nice huh all
right topic one Barclays has raised the
U.S GDP in its first quarter forecast
sees a mild recession led by the rise in
private consumption
okay let's hear your applause
sorry Sons
not jazzed I take it all right here's
the Second Story we got an update on the
Canadian High School teacher
foreign
[Applause]
and it sucks it sucks I got to tell you
because we actually had three qualified
experts on remote
uh to explain the economic forecast
I feel kind of bad look at him
nerds
roll it Janet
if it happens up there we report down
here you're watching gazumba gate Canada
2023
week 17.
yep it's time to cover the other Golden
Globes
well here's a quick memory summary
Chi what's what's a he began identifying
as female last year and started wearing
massive prosthetic breasts to class the
school board still stands behind the
teacher no other choice in the unlikely
event of a water emergency landing your
shop teacher can be used as a flotation
device we're trying to tackle this topic
with some measure of professionalism and
that measure is 68 triple D is this
truly a trans teacher or is it a prank
that's gotten way out of hand the shop
teacher was recently pictured in all her
immense booberry skydiving this story is
getting bigger and bouncier
and that it is because now we have an
update the Halton District School Board
in Ontario voted unanimously to ask its
education director to develop a
professionalism policy that includes a
dress code this in response to the trans
teacher who appears to identify as the
Grand Tetons foreign
you think such a code would already be
in place or at least you know instituted
months ago you know in September after
this Brave Little Show decided to tackle
a story that basically scared off
everyone else
yeah Fox and Friends put that in your
oatmeal and smoke it I mean we're
talking large breasts here how large
well the cast of The View likes to stand
next to them to appear thin oh
[Laughter]
we bedougedly covering this story for
months and it took until now for a dress
code to be drawn up the trucker protest
got shut down shut down in weeks but
knockers the size of 18 wheelers Outlast
the most marriages
but the long overdue policy might end up
like Basic Instinct when it runs on
network TV completely watered down they
take out all the good parts because the
Director of Education says the plan will
be drawn up with the help of employment
law firms with human rights and Equity
advisors you know what that means it's
going to suck it means that anything
that asks people to do something they
don't want to do must be obviously
discriminatory says the superintendent
quote even if a dress code is
implemented for non-discriminatory
reasons it would likely be found to be
discriminatory what does that mean you
weirdo but it's because of you jerk-offs
who really believe we can live on a
planet where nobody's feelings get hurt
and where everybody has to agree on
everything and everything has to be
decided by committee is it really so
much to ask that teachers refrain from
wearing prosthetic breasts so big
they're being considered as the site for
the next Winter Olympics
who would it discriminate against
lactating hippos
in other words you can now indulge a
fetish in public in front of kids
because wearing enormous prosthetic
boobs is now a human right so what does
that open doors to imagine a biological
female teacher coming to work with a
massive prosthetic penis strapped to her
person
I'm imagining it right now
okay
foreign
well good luck teaching trig with that
rig
at its time Common Sense prevails that's
all we really want either way the school
board is expecting an interim report
next month and a dress code policy in
March until then the udders that make
you shudder they aren't going anywhere
and as sure as the sun rises in the East
and sets in the west when it comes to
Giant boob stories Gutfeld does it best
[Applause]
he routinely checks his tattoos for
typos co-hosts of Fox and Friends
Weekend Pete exit
foreign
way too credible to be doing this show
Fox Business correspondent Jerry Willis
[Applause]
she considers Red Bull to be a sedative
Fox News contributor Kat Tim
[Applause]
ever under the weather it's under him my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
foreign
is this the first time on the show that
you've talked about this we I don't
think we've ever talked we've done this
this topic probably more than any other
topic and uh ever ever the history of
this show and the weekend show we did we
did two topics we did two shows on
Ukraine and we've done 20.
that's true that's our brand Greg I've
tried for months to get this story on
Fox and Friends Weekend really months I
believe that they won't touch it why not
because I love ratings and they don't
yes and you clearly do love radies I
didn't know you had a crack
investigative team we have been on top
of this like uh
Cross Your Heart bra
wow what a reference like a bro like a
bro uh this is totally unsurprising when
you live in a world where standards are
not allowed objective truth is not
allowed so of course the inclusion and
Equity advisors get involved which means
everything must be included to include
wearing that on your front uh it will
this will not work he or she will file
for discrimination and the school
district will lose because everyone's
lost their freaking mind yeah and unless
unless this is a long game prank which I
still believe the guy went guy went
skydiving with Canada's only right-wing
porn star who does that I'm with you I
think it could be a long-term and if
that is this this person wins the Nobel
Prize and there'll be a guest on this
[ __ ] oh they'll have my job
Jerry you're a business reporter I'm
sure you've been following this like
very closely
um
yes I'm going to talk about something
serious companies do did companies stop
having dress codes like if I came to Fox
and were anything goes anything goes
right anything goes you can't have rules
anymore to your point uh it just doesn't
exist but I was you know doing my
research for this very topic as you know
I read all the notes on the business I
know how to do this and there was one
phrase I could not get past and that was
Z cup yes a b c d z cup I just it didn't
compute for me and I didn't get past I
only hear that when I go to a coffee
house in France I have a z cup of uh
oh thank you thank you I'm glad I fed
you that thank you no it was it was uh
the worst my jokes are the happier I am
why I'm never depressed
well what do you I mean to this so
um do you believe this is real or do
okay is this a fetish this in my opinion
this isn't a real trans person it's a
fetishist a fetishist indulges a
specific time it's not about what you
wear to work this is not about what you
wear to work I'm sorry it's not about a
dress code a dress code is something
totally different right am I crazy or
yeah no no you're not crazy no no it's
crazy I think
you're nuts all right cat one of the
things that I argue always and you have
too is like if he really wanted to be a
woman
he would choose to look like a woman not
a caricature of a woman this isn't about
being a woman it's about uh creating a
getting off on being looked at would you
would you agree with me
I want who Okay Canada like don't Sue
please because then we're gonna have to
talk about it more
I'm very disturbed by something in this
story it said um an interim Port is
respect expected next month yes that's
not looking good for me
and how is it possible that we know so
little really about this person exactly
why is this person anybody in the
greater Toronto area have have you
spoken to this person this does not
appear to me to be a shy person no no
but you know that if you take a picture
of him in school you will be suspended
that is a fact high school kids cannot
take but I did know that again you've
got I I I'm really dialed into this yes
for my job which I I never imagined when
I was in school like what do you what do
you want to do why are you in college I
didn't see this
in my future but how is that possible
how is it not even anonymously like this
is a person of neighbors does this
person have you know somebody they got
an omelet at a diner yes Anonymous yeah
he can't drive to work in that he can't
drive so he's obviously changing in the
parking lot I know that like we always
say like you know you sometimes can
think Canada is not like a real country
or whatever but they do a really good
they do a better job of locking down
information about this Canadian boob
teacher than like our government
officials do with actual classified
information
see you don't want to talk about it and
then you bring it home with some
brilliant analysis because I have to to
get paid and have health insurance
remind me about that health insurance I
got to talk to you after this I use it
yeah not anymore though
[Laughter]
Tyrus last word to you
come on
what
you're a strumpet
dirty little strumpet for this story I
am I am
and you're part of the Soiree you're all
struggled
and we've and we fell we fell for it
dress code yes what's gonna cover that
up a tent like what what turtleneck is
gonna cover that up nothing there's no
dress code they just they don't have the
guts to say take it off right it's
inappropriate at school what language do
you use in the dress code exactly they
you cannot cover wear giant yeah
if you're if your nipples are 12 inches
wide yes
unless you have a doctor's note you
can't have them at school
you have to have some sort
of medical issue
12-inch wide nipples than where everyone
will go ah and not take pictures of it
we have to blur the nipples that the
students see they can't blur it
themselves because their nipples blur
their eyes yes hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else